salut aujourd'hui on est jeudi le jeudi
c'est le genre de je fais ce que je veux
et on a décidé ensemble de faire des
facs hui snapshot vous me l'avez demandé
et bien je le fais alors comment ça se
passe le plus ancien au plus récent j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a que je peux
plus déjà lire peut-être c'est dans les
réglages vous aviez mal fait parce que
j'en ai ouvert aucun il y en a que je
peux plus ouvrir bon écouteront on verra
bien mais mais je crois que j'en ai
perdu plein plein plein bad désolé pour
ceux sur laquelle ça bug je pense que
c'est dans les réglages que vous avez
envoyé que ça pouvait pas durer autant
de temps j'en sais rien en fait mais
tous ceux qui sont déjà en blanc je les
ai pas ouvert et je peux pas les lire
alors au moins j'ouvre ce que je peux
lire c'est beaucoup la légère ce qui
touche les questions c'est aussi longue
on s'en sortira jamais en clair mais tes
connaissances et techniques au service
des gens dans le besoin par rapport à la
mémoire d'accord ok écoute je crois que
je le fais déjà gaza c'est un peu cette
chaîne elle fait déjà ce à quoi j'ai pas
de projet clairement définis pour faire
ça plus que ça mais au moins j'essaye de
partager soit les soies méconnaissance
soit ce que j'utilise moi avec vous par
la chaîne youtube après il ya juste à le
transmettre aux bonnes personnes si vous
voulez le transmettre maîtrise tu le
magnétisme voir les pneus est-ce que tu
t'en sers le magnétisme c'est pour moi
ça fait partie des choses que je range
du côté les croyances donc on y croit ou
pas ça fonctionne ou pas j'ai me croit
quand je vous avais les autres mais mais
il n'y a pas de fondement scientifique
alors que l'hypnose oui ok pour amy
alors du coup les autres et ouais c'est
ça les autres je peux pas les ouvrir
mais je suis désolé des coups je suis
dégoûté jeu sera le plein de vos
questions du coup je sais pas pourquoi
comment autre truc ça lui va bien je
vais te dire que j'adore ce que tu fais
pour la fac eu qu'à les études as-tu
fait et comment es tu es tu devenu
mentalist j'ai fait des études qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le mentaliste puisque
j'ai fait un bac scientifique après j'ai
fait plutôt des formations mes études
mes études sont plus des formations en
fait que le parcours classique comment
je suis devenu mentalist j'avais déjà un
peu répondu à cette question je
mentalise pour moi c'est un mot
fourre-tout chacun sa propre définition
mais mon parcours personnel ça a été
d'avoir une très très bonne mémoire en
fait dès le départ on s'en est aperçu
lors d'un test de qi quand j'ai des
petits parce qu'il y avait un test sur
le fait de mémoriser des trucs bref on
s'est éclaté ensuite j'ai découvert la
magie dans un livre de magie de robert v
no qui s'appelle cours magica il y avait
toute une partie sur le mentalisme qui
m'a beaucoup interpellé et après je me
suis ouvert à la lecture de plein de
bouquins qui était sur la mémoire sur le
comportemental sur les choses comme ça
et c'est tout ce fourre tout qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui
je suis là continuons avec marie
pourquoi j'entends pas de question à mon
mari si marie je n'entends pas la
question je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
la faq snapshot la moins organisés de la
planète colas pour cette image sache que
le jour où il faudra que je te fasse
monter dans un vaisseau cosmique de la
vierge marie
je ne prendrai pas manu ça lui va bien
j'ai une question pour tourner dit
souvent que personne plus intelligente
ou celle qui analyse beaucoup le plus
leurs projets sont plus solidaires que
la normale est ce le cas pour toi oui
c'est pour ça que je me fais des avis
sur youtube à le dictionnaire de
l'impossible mortels il est trop bien ce
bouquin tu as eu raison de l'acheter
genre j'en parlais dans une des
premières vidéos des jeudis du
dictionnaire de l'impossible dommage ce
décalage j'espère que tu vas 1 et
sablières et bien non justement
effectivement je ne vois pas les samedis
hier je sais pas pourquoi je sais pas
comment ça se fait le le dit cheikh
l'impossible je vous mets dans les
descriptifs question bonus tu passes
quand à nantes les farc d'autruche
d'attendre je passerai à nantes pour
roder le nouveau spectacle donc en début
2010 est je crois tu avais le
dictionnaire d'un possible c'est ainsi
que par un bouquin un lien elle est
hyper intéressant je vous mettrai dans
les liens dans le descriptif effet bien
comment as tu découvert le mentalisme
question répondu qu'ils sont les
principaux passe-t-on en dehors des
vidéos
ah ah ça c'est une bonne question
quelles sont mes principaux passe temps
j'en ai plein à la base je joue beaucoup
au jeu vidéo sauf que j'y joue plus du
tout depuis une bonne dizaine d'années
parce que je sais pas ce temps et je
vraiment addict aux jeux vidéo c'est
ainsi je commence à jouer je vais jouer
cinq six sept heures d'affilée assez
rapidement donc donc je joue plus
tellement j'aime beaucoup le
parachutisme mais j'ai pas trop le temps
d'en faire souvent je cours aussi oui je
cours cette silhouette élancée ne vient
pas de nulle part
mon vrai le loisir principal c'est
d'apprendre mais c'est vrai je lis
beaucoup je cherche beaucoup de choses
sur internet
j'aime bien comprendre les choses en
fait une manière générale
accor fait rien eh bien je te répondrais
correct les micros pression alors les
micros pression ce sont de petites
bières comme ça des petites pressions et
donc et donc j'ai pas de balma support
des vidéos continue comme ça est ce que
tu pourrais refaire une vidéo avec
pierre cros et as tu déjà penser à ce
que tu allais faire après l'été 366
vidéo est ce que tu vas t'en sera une
année de plus de vidéos une autre vidéo
avec pierre cros oui si on a une idée
pourquoi pas s'il a envie aussi
évidemment après les 366 vidéo c'est une
question qui revient souvent est ce que
je vais continuer ou pas en fait au
départ je me suis pas projeté sur sur ce
que j'allais faire après puisque je ne
connaissais rien aux vidéos rien et
youtube j'ai lancé ça le 1er janvier
comme ça pour voir et je veux me prend
au jeu grâce à vous et ce projet là est
tellement dense en fait rajouter au
reste de ma vie au reste de mon travail
sur scène que déjà je veux le mener à
bien déjà que j'aille jusqu'au 31
en faisant une vidéo par jour ce sera
déjà énorme pour moi qui connaissait
rien tout ça avant évidemment je ne vois
pas tout arrêter maintenant du jour au
lendemain ce serait stupide et puis j'ai
pas envie de ça en fait j'ai envie de
continuer mais sous quelle forme quelle
rythme quoi comment je sais pas je sais
une chose c'est que je ressortirai pas
une vidéo le 1er janvier merci beaucoup
ça va être très plaisir c'est bien fait
ou pas mais c'est bien dégueulasse ça
est-ce que j'ai mérité confiance à
thomas faq
il est quelle heure il est midi et demi
je vais manger enfin j'allais manger
enfin je vais pu manger plus jamais
merci beaucoup
pourquoi as-tu appris toutes ces choses
question déjà traités alors qu'est ce
qui t'a inciter à devenir mentalist et
quel était ton métier avant 2100 de
l'ordinateur et je vous jure on va y
arriver je suis désolé série a je suis
désolé est ce que tu fais du sport merci
pour ce que tu fais c'est quoi c'est ton
ventre ça ou alors c'est un biceps
peut-être deux côtés oui je fais du
sport donc je cours depuis longtemps
j'aime bien ça c'est vraiment un truc
qui me fait du bien
la tête et je me suis inscrit dans une
salle de sport il ya trois semaines
donc c'est très récent je vais à la
salle ouais je vais à la salle thibault
en chef n'a qu'à bien se tenir
moi aussi je suis sec et gros thibault
fais attention à toi hashtag je suis un
crayon b mais ça me fait plaisir
ah oui c'est tout je fais très attention
parce que j'ai un pote on voit des
hashtags je suis un taille-crayon les
filles toi alors on aimerait savoir ce
que tu as fait comme études et commenta
des probables de mentalisme et surtout
pourquoi tu as décidé de voir transposer
le mentalisme au théâtre pouce en l'air
hermine hermine amin amin je te connais
armin on s'est rencontré à mulhouse au
spectacle est remis toutes les questions
je les ai déjà traitées sauf pourquoi au
théâtre et ça c'est cool comme question
mon vrai choix c'est d'être allé sur
scène dans un terreau est donc ça m'a
toujours attiré la scène j'ai eu un
groupe de musique d'ailleurs il ya très
longtemps j'ai mis une photo là dessus
sur instagram bière sera versé drôle une
photo qu'on a retrouvé j'ai 16 ans
dessus donc marrant vie professionnelle
c'est est de divertir les gens donc
d'aller sur scène en tant que comédien
de divertir les gens et moi ma passion à
la base c'est le mentalisme d'où le fait
de faire de mentalisme sur scène
j'espère que ça répond à ta question
c'est en dehors ben merci beaucoup merci
je t'adore aussi pourrais-tu faire une
vidéo comment ne pas avoir des blancs
dans une conversation
c'est marrant ça fait plein de fois vous
me demandez ça dans les commentaires des
vidéos sur comment ne pas avoir les
blancs dans une conversation je lui il
faut que je trouve un angle mais on peut
faire une astuce à mercredi là dessus ou
peut-être même un master class
c'est plus sur la cool aux conversations
dans la globalité parce que j'ai
l'impression que vous avez des peurs des
blancs en fait c'est eux
je vais me pencher là dessus c'était pas
le premier en parlait en fait pourquoi
tu as préféré tourner vers le mentaliste
est pas la magie comme la magie des
cartes où la magie des pièces merci
beaucoup pour cette question la première
question vidéo qui fonctionne alors
pourquoi vers le mentaliste c'est vrai
que j'ai découvert le mot mentalisme via
la magie ce que je disais tout à l'heure
dans le livre de robert v no
du coup je fais de la magie un jeu fait
des cartes choix des pièces je fais pas
mal de choses j'ai même eu quelques prix
dans la magie en 2007 j'avais leucan
d'or j'avais eu un prix aussi parlement
drac dorment ça c'était dans la magie
aussi et après c'est une question de
goût en fait tu fais ce qu'il te plaît
le plus dans la vie c'est pour ça qu'on
en a qui deviennent plus dans la nuit ce
magie la magie des pièces doute dans
l'image et écarte voilà réponse pas très
clair quand même ah ah ah c'est pas bête
en fait l'idée c'est que tu aimerais
voir le tour que j'explique le dimanche
tu aimerais le voir en action
je crois que c'est ça que tu veux c'est
le comme le dimanche je vous explique un
tour ou de magie ou de mentalist vous
aimeriez le voir en action sur quelqu'un
qu'il connaît pas dans une vidéo
c'est possible je peux je peux faire ça
je peux faire ça en plus peut-être que
ça peut-être que ça réglera un souci que
j'ai dans les tours dimanche les temps
dimanche souvent vous le fait voir
comment ça fonctionne c'est pour
l'explication mais c'est pas pour vous
bluffez vous c'est pas ça la promesse et
seconde mi temps est gris gameex
certains marchés sur moi alors c'est pas
le but
le but c'est que nous l'expliquent à
chaque fois donc forcément c'est pas des
choses qui sont adaptables forcément aux
caméras quoi donc ça pourrait être
intéressant à écouter vous me le dis
dans le commentaire si vous voulez que
je mette en application une fois dans la
semaine le tour que j'explique le
dimanche on peut faire ça voilà ça va
trop vite astrid
j'ai pas eu le temps de tout lire je
vois deux pouces en l'air je vois des
pouces en l'air avant que ça ça fait
tous tous d'arrosoir plus lui landrier
pouce de du nord ben pouce de café pouce
de téléphone tous de france pousse de
bercy mais non à sa doit-on petit garçon
ça à nantes vous êtes trop influençable
mais c'est bien fait de pouce astrid as
they d'ailleurs que vous avez eue dans
une vidéo il n'y a pas longtemps fulham
est en jeu vous la met en lien
déjà c'est un bon pseudo sachions fion
mais dans le mentalisme a dit ce qu'on
va se marrer fillon barbecue au lycée
pour le spectacle des élèves
voilà tout à fait pertinent pour cette
faq coucou je viens de voir qu'il me
reste tout juste deux minutes pour poser
ma question
comme j'ai vu un joli labrador sur
internet j'aurais voulu savoir si tu
devais être un animal lequel se serait
et pourquoi merci see
devait être un animal mais je veux être
un chat évidemment que je vais être un
chat je veut dominer le monde
d'une manière générale être un chat
permet de dominer le monde
en dormant 20 heures par jour je vais
être un chat est ce que je compte faire
une vidéo sur l'hypnose oui sûrement
durant l'année j'en ferais je pense
c'est pas programmer mes joueurs frais
sur moi mais si c'est dur mais bien sûr
que c'est dur de faire une vidéo par
jour pendant un an je n'avais pas du
tout pris l'ampleur du projet c'est dur
mais c'est vraiment super cool par
compte mais mais mais dis donc tu fais
peur avec ce filtre là le multi mme
ironman évidemment c'est pas du tout
inutile si je passe dans les facs ug
crée ton nom sur mes deux bras pendant
tous le vendredi on veut voir ça et on
veut des preuves vous faut que tu
m'aides ça aussi sur facebook comme tag
ans pour que pour qu'on puisse avoir la
preuve que ya ton nom sur les bras tout
vendre quelle est ma date d'anniversaire
à c'est vrai qu'on ne trouve pas trop
parce que je le même pas mis sur
facebook parce que ça m'énervait en fait
d'avoir tous les trucs sur facebook
alors que je sais que c'est juste
facebook qui notifie l'anniversaire
oulala j'ai l'impression d'être monsieur
smith dans matrix je me fais gaffe à ça
je suis né le 22 novembre 1901 quelque
chose je suis donc un scorpion je suis
pas salutaire ça lui ferait mieux ce que
tu prévois de descendre sur toulouse
pour rencontrer les amener autour d'un
bon petit verre quand il était vidéo est
son super merci c'est vraiment cool
comme message je vais revenir sur
toulouse pour jouer le spectacle donc on
pourra se voir way en même temps
sûrement après le spectacle où ça dépend
de combien de temps je reste j'avais
joué au zénith de toulouse pour le
printemps du rire j'ai joué aussi au rex
de l'humour qui est le théâtre d
questerre des chevaliers du fiel donc je
reviendrai à toulouse avec le nouveau
spectacle c'est sûr et un bon petit
verre comme dit ali dans la ville
harrah's non je n'utilise jamais mes
connaissances à des fins personnelles
comme vous avez pu le constater dans les
trous story des écoutes ya rien de
programmé pour l'instant en italie j'ai
déjà joué en italie parliez de bateaux
de croisière et que philippe roesch que
vous avez déjà vu ici aussi mais là j'ai
rien de prévu en italie n'en a cool et
bbm annoncé cool que t'es pas une
question mais que je sache que tu que tu
fais la traduction
en espagne des vidéos c'est vraiment
cool d'ailleurs tu sais que si tu veux
tu peux sous-titré les vidéos en
espagnol directement sur youtube comme
ça ça permet dans le monde accessible
aux espagnols les gens profitent comme
je fais temps en temps pour remercier
tous ceux d'entre vous qui sous titre
les vidéos en français pour qu'elle soit
accessible aux malentendants merci
beaucoup merci à tous ceux qui font du
sous titrage ça c'est vraiment énorme
j'ai un peu je suis un peu déçu pour le
bug je pense que si on avait fait un
live comme je voulais le faire au départ
je les aurai ouvert au fur et à mesure
en fait ça doit être aussi pour ça quand
même à partir d'un certain délai
peut-être on peut pas les ouvrir dites
moi dans les commentaires si vous voulez
qu'un ses cartons se refasse une faq
snapshot et est ce que ce coup ci on
cela fasse en live directement où
j'ouvre en temps réel je fais la vidéo
en temps réel et vous les envoyer sur
sur un créneau on se prévoit de trois
heures comme ça et je les ouvre et je
filme en continu
on fera comme ça ce sera mieux du coup
merci en tout cas à vous un d'avoir
envoyé toutes ces étapes toutes ces
questions j'espère que les réponses sont
satisfaisantes j'espère qu'elle vous
plaisent
n'oubliez pas le défi que je me suis
lancé à 50 mille abonnés j'organiserai
une soirée où je vais vous présenter des
morceaux du nouveau spectacle met en
mode comme ça informelle en buvant un
coup qu'on puisse discuter tout ça ce
sera une espèce de mental ce sera un
miteux mais où je ferai un petit peu de
mentalisme aussi avec vous et vous donne
tous les détails dans la vidéo numéro
100 là dessus merci aussi de partager
les vidéos c'est ce qui ramène des
nouvelles personnes dans dans la morale
team non dans la team mental ou parce
que ça c'est notre nom à nous qui nous
unit et j'ai tapé dans le pied de caméra
prenez bien soin de vous si vous voulez
aussi qu'on fasse il m'avait fait qu une
deuxième fois qu snapshot mais en temps
réel dites le moi dans les commentaires
ou alors vous laissez simplement aussi
un pouce en l'air parce que pouce en
l'air ça fait plaisir
je vais vous faire un petit snap de fin
pour vous dire que c'est fini ainsi
s'achève la vidéo 140 sur les 366 de
stan et merci encore une fois pour tous
un vrai qu'il de vous faire ces vidéos
et rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour
le prochain mentale fleuve chao